au milieu des véhicules calcinés
partout des soldats russes le long de la
route de kherson
cette grande ville du sud de l'ukraine
est tombée aux mains des russes début
mars au début du conflit les combats ont
été brefs mais ensuite la population à
manifester contre la présence
nous sommes parmi les tous premiers
journalistes occidentaux à y entrer
c'est l'armée russe qui nous
accompagnent le message qu'elle veut
faire passer tout est redevenu paisible
il nous emmène d'abord dans ce
laboratoire de contrôle de l'eau pour
vanter leur bonne gestion
on ma vie de faire la visite alors on
vous fait la visite là on a un stockage
et là c'est un placard de séchage
objectif avec ce dépôt de bus un peu
plus loin montré que la moitié des
lignes de la ville fonctionne
nous n'avons pas le droit d'aller parler
à la population
les russes reconnaissent qu'elles
auraient hostile mais au détour de la
visite un peu à l'écart cet contrôleuse
veut se confier à nous
je n'ai pas peur qu'est ce que je risque
s'il me tue il me tue elle raconte
qu'avec elle les soldats russes se sont
toujours bien comportés mais elle veut
les voir partir je suis pour le pouvoir
ukrainien je vis en ukraine je suis
ukrainienne je vis sur ma terre et je
veux que personne reste libre je veux
que cela soit comme avant avant on
vivait bien et tranquillement
sur les façades de la ville on voit
encore les drapeau ukrainien qui n'ont
pas été effacés mais c'est bien le
drapeau russe qui flottent sur les
bâtiments officiels
en arrivant les russes disait ne pas
vouloir annexer la région aujourd'hui le
discours a changé vêtu d'un gilet
pare-balles ce nouveau responsable pro
russe annonce la couleur
nous sommes une entité et la région de
kherson et nous rentrerons dans la
fédération de russie en tant que région
à part entière de la fédération de
russie le front n'est qu'à une trentaine
de kilomètres
dans toute la région les russes sont sur
leurs gardes
pour résister à une contre attaque
ukrainienne ils ont construit tranché et
fortifications au bord de la mer noire
ce cas d'offre est le lieu de
villégiature des habitants de personnes
ici face à nos questions la population
se montre fuyante
ou diplomates
on voudrait être un état en dehors des
blocs neutre comme la suisse ou la suède
la suisse est un petit pays qui vit
depuis 200 ans sans faire la guerre ni
rouillou
la région et stratégiques
sa richesse c'est l'agriculture et
surtout l'eau du dniepr qui la
traversent dès leur prise de contrôle
les russes ont détourné une partie du
fleuve ils ont rouvert le canal vers la
crim est fermé depuis huit ans
si l'armée russe a choisi de nous amener
ici c'est parce que cette région elle
est cruciale elle permet d'assurer la
continuité entre d'un côté la crimée
qu'ils ont annexé en 2014 et de l'autre
le dombass contrôlés par des
séparatistes pro-russes